en las alturas de villar de los navarros
en el norte de españá gigantescos
mástiles con sus palas móviles en este
lugar muy expuesto al viento un grupo
hispano italiano desarrolló una de las
mayores plantas de molinos de viento del
país
es una zona de alta incidencia de viento
tenemos unas
2500 3.000 horas de viento anuales lo
que significa pues bueno una producción
eólica que va a significar unos 471
gigavatios/hora año y lo que significará
el consumo anual de 148 mil hogares a lo
largo y ancho de españa los proyectos
eólicos se multiplican hasta tal punto
que el año pasado la energía eólica se
convirtió en la primera fuente de
electricidad del país por delante de la
nuclear y del gas con más de 1.200
parques eólicos españa es el quinto país
del mundo y el segundo de la unión
europea por detrás de alemánia que más
apuesta por esta energía un mercado que
interesa los inversores según
representantes del sector bueno
españoles es un país con un potencial
tremendo como granero energético es
decir la capacidad de recurso que
tenemos en españa ambiente del sol el
territorio que tenemos y el tejido
productivo que tenemos a nivel
industrial pueden hacer a españa como el
gran productor de energía limpia para
europa de aquí a 2030 a madrid se
plantea un objetivo ambicioso que el 74
por ciento de la electricidad provenga
de fuentes renovables lo que significa
un tercio más que a día de hoy